前一段時間我發了一條貼文,
然後有一位網友的評論讓我感到很有感觸,
他用了普通人這三個字,
透露出一絲無奈和淒涼的感覺,
我們都知道看問題的方式和角度決定了一個人的人生,
如果你總是以普通人自居的話,
那麼你永遠是個普通人,
怎樣才能夠從普通人陷阱當中走出來呢?
我認為最重要最根本的就是改變你看世界的方式
今天我來講幾個我自己的小故事
希望這些故事能夠對你有啟發
我是1999年大學畢業
大學畢業以後我就留下做老師
當時我是在杭州
當時的工資只有900塊錢一個月人民幣
剛畢業的時候也沒有房
那麼自己要麼自己租房子住
要麼就是住集體宿舍
那麼我選擇自己租房住
後來到了2000年的時候
中國的房地產商業化就逐漸展開了
那麼普通人是可以貸款買房了
我當時作為教師
可以獲得不少貸款的優惠
當時我是看中了一套房
在杭州的鼓樓地區
位置是非常好的
房價19萬首付5萬
然後每個月大概是900塊錢的一月供
我當時手上的錢基本上只夠付首付
其實真正的難度是在後面
是在月供上面
因為月供基本上
等於我的工資了
那麼交完月供之後
我基本上就只能喝西北風了
我媽當時就說
這個房子太貴了
我們買不起
不過當然後來我還是買了
買不起是當時
大多數普通人
當時的第一直覺反應
那麼我的反應就是說
我想提高自己的生活
我不想租房住了
我希望自己的生活
上一個臺階
我可以用我的工資
去還月供
那麼我在想辦法
從業餘時間當中去
去拓展一些這個收入渠道
我當時是在美術學院工作
那麼空餘的時間呢
也是比較多的
那麼我們美術學院的老師
基本上都在想辦法掙錢
其實呢
我在讀大學的過程當中
就一直在做一些商業項目
因為那個時候
剛好趕上了這個
中國的這個房地產
慢慢起步的這樣的一個
一個浪潮
所以說我認為
我是有能力
可以掙到這個錢
來還這個房貸的
那麼為了還這個房貸
那麼我也擴大了
我自己的設計工作室
招了人
成立了公司
那麼項目也是越做越大
那麼我的第一桶金
就是來自於
我自己做設計公司
買了這個房之後
2010年
我辭職
離開杭州
去上海發展的時候
我這套房已經漲了10倍
這個故事我想表達的是
我們不能夠被自己的當前的狀態
限制住了自己的想象力
而是要用想象力
去拓展自己的能力圈
去開發自己的潛力
如果我不是想提升自己的生活水平
我就不會去想買這個房
當時買房還是有風險
對不對
有很多事情
你不知道未來會怎樣
當時的房
對很多普通人來說
也都是負擔不起的
如果不是因為買這個房
那麼我也就不會去開這個公司
我不會有這個公司
就不會有我的第一桶金
對不對
那麼有了第一桶金
有了一定的資本之後
那麼我需要更廣泛的自由
所以後來才會從零開始學習投資
然後再一步一步
現在移民到海外
那麼我現在自己的生活
簡單來說就是四個字
叫做自由富足
這一切其實都是源於當初的一個想法
說到底就是我不想做個普通人
如果你也有同樣的想法
我下面再講幾個小故事
希望對你有啟發
我讀大學本科時候
學的是環境藝術設計
研究生讀的是纖維藝術
它是雕塑藝術下面的一個研究方向
前面我說了
我的第一桶金是來自於我的本專業
是設計
但是我在2010年以後的生活和發展
就全部都是靠投資了
但是不管怎麼說
一個學藝術的人跨界到了金融領域
那麼對於普通人來說
這是一個非常大的跨越
我是怎樣實現這種跨越的呢
我認為首先就是要拓展自己的知識結構
1995年到2000年左右
中國大陸的房地產市場逐漸商業化
那麼對建築對環境設計的需求是非常大的
那麼我這個專業
在當時算是一個
恰好趕上了好時代
所以我很早就接觸到這些商業
這種這些領域
那麼我對商業
對創業
對經濟方面的這些內容
也都是非常的感興趣
這就使得我的知識結構
很自然的從藝術設計
這種美學框架
逐漸就拓展到了
更廣泛的這種商業領域
我很早就訂閱了
像華爾街日報
經濟學人
這些著名的這些媒體
那個時候在中國
不需要翻牆
就可以看得到這些東西的
就是到了2003年以後
這個就越來越難了
就不得不翻牆了
那麼為了看這些內容
就沒辦法就搞懂了翻牆
對吧
然後搞懂了
怎樣使用這種國際信用卡支付
那麼還順便知道了
那裡有一個美國的股票市場
然後當我發現了
美股這個大金礦以後
我就開始想辦法把資金移入海外
更重要的是呢
就是做這些事情
讓我逐漸有了這種國際的視野
翻牆出來
最開始是用這個翻譯軟件看英文
那麼後來久而久之
英文水平也有了一定的提高
那麼英文水平提高以後呢
又讓這個視野更加的打開了
那麼在知識結構有了一定的
這個擴展之後呢
就有了拓展自己朋友圈的
這樣的一個願望
有一句話說的是
你的五個朋友決定了你的認知水平
如果你身邊的人都喜歡刷短視頻
喜歡聊八卦
那麼你很難接觸到所謂的這種破壞性創新
或者說資本偏好這類話題
所以說拓展朋友圈是非常必要的
如果說你對投資感興趣
就應該儘可能的多結交這種投資圈
創業圈的朋友
當然了在現實生活當中
普通人要想跨越自己的階層
或者說跨越自己的圈子
去別人的圈子
去有錢人的圈子
那是相當不容易的
但是呢
現在呢
這個網絡這麼發達
一些有意思的這種論壇
股東會啊
什麼大師課之類的
我認為是有必要去
去學一學
去看一看的
那麼如果說有投資方面的圈子
也可以結識到一些牛人
我記得以前我在上海的時候
那個時候雪球每年會舉行一個雪球大會
在那個大會上面也會認識到一些投資圈的朋友
那麼還有一段就是說
有一些投資圈的大咖開的社群
我認為也是可以參與的
當然了大多數的好東西都是要付費的
而且並不便宜
總而言之
我認為找一個靠譜的圈子
帶著問題去找答案
看看有沒有人能解決你的問題
如果沒有那就再換一個圈子
有時候某一個人的一句話
可以改變你的人生
接下去我還有一個小故事
專門講這件事情
學會提問
這是最快的學習方式
是進步最快的學習方式
不要以為付費的內容都是割韭菜
購買付費的內容
反正你就帶著你的思想
帶著你的問題進去
打開畫夾子
說完你的問題
看誰能幫你解決
解決完了也走
不解決也走
對不對
那麼我自己的購買這些付費內容
我有一個經驗
就是說我從來不買那種付年費
年費看上去便宜
但實際上有一種不舒服的感覺
我寧可貴一點
我也願意
就是說一個月一個月的付
不滿意我隨時可以走
我沒有多大損失
那麼感覺好的話
我隨時也可以再回來
我的自己的社群
我也是取消了年費
你願意進來
隨時來都可以
你有什麼話題
我們可以聊
聊完你走
最核心的一點就是
你想得到什麼
有一個觀念
就是說叫做第一性原則
用第一性原則來思考問題
會讓你的人生變得非常的簡單
我做投資
從設計跨界到了做投資
那麼我的主要目的
並不是賺更多的錢
因為在當時
我的業務非常好
我的設計公司
這個項目做不完
如果我想賺更多的錢
我只需要僱傭更多的人
把公司規模搞大就可以了
這個賺錢的思路
但是呢
我發現這種生意模式
無法降低邊際成本
越做大人就越多
人越多越難管理
越難管理
最後就形成了一個死循環
雖然可以賺很多錢
但是它不是一種
看得見的指數級的增長
所以說呢
我希望是用錢來賺錢
賺最容易賺到的錢
這是我的第一行原則
我可以接受資本增長的速度慢一點
但是我希望它能夠自己成長
不需要我付出額外的努力
在我睡覺的時候它也能夠增長
這是對我來說
我反覆在思考的一件事情
那麼我這兩年在網絡上分享的
一個high five組合
一個投資組合
它就是符合我的第一行原理
解決問題的這種方案
我分享這個組合呢
就是想用這個實例
來告訴所有人
這是普通人積累財富
最快最簡單的路徑
你不相信
那我就做給你看
這就是我為什麼
要公開這件事情
我把所有的詳細記錄
都公佈在網上
在下面這個網址
你就可以找得到
我做了11年的大學老師
我是有那麼一點點
傳教士精神的
我就是喜歡
把我認為好的東西
傳播給更多的人
我享受這個過程
進一步說
第一性原理
簡單來說
如果放在每個人身上
你思考一下
如果說你的目標
是獲得職位升遷
通過加班努力是沒有出路的
你需要為你的公司
解決更大的問題
創造更大的價值
提升你在公司當中的重要性
那麼自然你的地位
就會得到提升
那麼如果說你的目的
你的目標是賺更多的錢
那麼靠別人去推薦幾隻牛股給你是沒有前途的
你要知道沒有牛股一直漲
它的波動的過程當中是會讓你非常痛苦的
所以說你要用一種策略
或者說是用槓桿的方式去放大收益
這些內容在我的YouTube頻道你都可以找得到
總而言之想清楚你要什麼
然後根據目標去設計你的路徑
這才是解決問題的正確的姿勢
前面我也說了
就是說我發現我做設計公司
這個商業模式
不符合我的第一性原理
但是我當時並不知道怎樣去解決
對吧
那麼但是這個思考
一直在我的腦海裡頭轉
直到有一次機緣巧合
在2004年
我做了一個湖北武漢的一個設計項目
當時這個設計項目的老闆
後來我知道
他是一個當年在杭州
做商品期貨的一個高手
我和老闆
老闆姓餘
我們就叫餘總
餘總我跟他有一次
因為設計上面的一些觀念的衝突
發生了一次很激烈的爭吵
那麼在這一次爭吵當中
餘總有一段話
對我的衝擊是非常非常大
大概的意思就是說
他說你們這些學藝術的人
學設計的人
就是有點自以為是
自以為清高
自以為自己很優秀很特別
但是我告訴你
我選你來做這個項目
不是因為你優秀你特別
而是因為我不想再花更多的時間
去挑選別人了
你還行
所以用你
對於我來說
用你和用別人沒差別
你們只是我實現這個目標的工具而已
你能想象我當時的這個心情嗎
不過呢
因為我當時一直在思考
我怎麼樣去解決我這個問題
第一性原理的這個問題
所以我當時並沒有去跟他去爆發
所以我還是耐下心子聽他說
說完以後
我把我在腦海裡想的這些顧慮
這些問題說出來
我說於總
我碰到了這樣的問題
給我出點主意
然後就是這樣的一次談話之後
於總為我解開了我的疑惑
讓我明白
投資是符合我的第一性思考
後來我就開設了人生當中的第一個投資賬戶
是一個期貨賬戶
也正是這一次這個機緣巧合
我就非常幸運的
在中國的這個同期貨的大牛市當中
賺到了人生的第二桶金
第一桶金是我的設計
做設計公司
那麼第二桶金就是用我做設計賺來的錢
放到資本市場放大
成為了我的第二桶金
也是受到這個餘總的影響
那麼我做投資的起點是非常高的
我並沒有大多數人的這種散戶思維
那麼我投入的金額是比較大的
投入的時間也是非常多的
甚至後來我把公司逐漸的脫手
我專心來做投資
我想說的是
如果說有人對你說的話非常的刺耳
你可能碰上貴人
那是你成長的機會
這年頭大家都很忙的
沒有沒有人願意在你身上多花一分一分錢時間的
對不對
那麼如果說有人願意在你身上花時間
願意對我說壞話
有人願意在我的評論區留言
這都是非常好的東西
我一直認為這個黑粉才是死忠粉
他們對我的批評都是都是非常好的
我是非常在意的
雖然我事後可以把他們拉黑
但是我絕對不會忽視他們的建議的
總而言之
我們不能只看跟自己觀念
相同的
跟自己觀念相一致的觀點
思維的碰撞
有些人從反方向來觀察你
他提出你的這個弱點
這是非常好的
對不對
思維的碰撞比認同更有價值
那麼我自己的在性格上面
也有一個特點
就是說
我不會把一件事情
想到百分之百再去做
我差不多想到百分之六七十
感覺模糊正確了
那麼我就會去做
那麼我們經常會聽到這樣的一種說法
說等我有了錢我就去移民
我就去全職投資
這種句式其實是把條件
看得比目標更重要
言下之意就是說
如果說沒有錢
那我就放棄這個目標
我就放棄這個目的
那麼我可以毫不客氣的說
凡是用這種套路說話的人
最終都是無法達成目標的
我的人生只有一個目標
就是更廣泛的自由
和更高品質的生活
這兩件事情是相輔相成的
如果說沒有自由
就談不上什麼高品質的生活
所以我把這兩個目標
合而為一
變成一個目標
所以我所有的人生歷程
人生經歷
所有的坎坷
成功
快樂
痛苦
都是我希望
是朝著這個目標方向前進的
這個聽上去好像很寬泛
但其實執行起來非常簡單
每當我要做任何選擇的時候
或者說要花錢
或者說要付出精力等等
我都會思考一下
我做這件事情
會不會讓我變得更自由
會不會讓我的生活提高一個檔次
或者說朝著我想要的方向發展
如果答案是
那我就去做
不論多大的代價
我都會去做
如果說是否定的
那就不做
很簡單
我認為去到那個目標的那個過程
比結果更重要
人生就是上臺階
一臺階一臺階往上走
很多時候你也只能是走一步看一步
但是目標必須是非常清晰的
至少那個方向必須是非常清晰
我希望我的每一步都更接近那個目標
或者說每一步都是朝著
那個模糊正確的方向在走
那麼這個過程就是快樂
東拉西扯說了這麼多
我就想說
如果說你想過得跟普通人不一樣
你不想做個普通人
那麼首先
想辦法去擴展自己的認知
然後擴展自己的圈子
最重要的是
搞清楚你想要什麼
有一些人
有一些事讓你不舒服
你要注意
它有可能會改變你的人生
總而言之
一定要讓你的目標
你的方向非常的明確
讓每一次的選擇
更接近目標
好
那麼就說這些我的故事
希望對你有啟發